we're carrying on from the business from
Thursday the 18th of June we run out of
time but we've got four items that we
need to discuss this evening just before
we start I've got apologies from council
of ricks tenets and it counts what
Thomas is standing in for countless
tenets I'm very grateful to him for that
okay so go to the first item on
tonight's agenda and that's on page 53
that's 132 Stockport rolling simple and
we have an introduction to this from mr.
Pearson mr. Pearson yes Thank You
chairman I'll just try and share my
screen bring up the drawing so you can
just bear with me a minute please
[Music]
could everybody see that now yeah that's
good yeah okay so this is an application
it's a house extension at 132 stock
Court Road simply and it's being
reported to committee because the
applicants council employee application
relates to a 2-story semi-detached the
left-hand one of that of that pear road
and it's surrounded by other similar
property properties got an existing
single-story rear extension and a rear
conservatory which you can see on the
bottom photo bottom left there and
they've got detached out buildings along
boundary with number 134 which is the
one to the right of it one three four
has also had extensions rear as is
number 130 which you can see just there
top top right so I'll just share the
site plan with you
the proposal comprises a two-story side
extension very narrow on down this side
it leaves a one metre gap to that
boundary and it projects out from the
back of the original house by 0.7 meters
of both ground and first floor at this
point that just ground there then I can
show you the floor plans there it's just
to provide additional living
accommodation without creating any new
bedrooms and then on to the elevational
drawings you can see the rear elevation
in the bottom left of your screen there
so it's single-story next to the
adjoining house and two-story away from
that boundary we consider their design
to be acceptable as well with the
existing property that's going to be
built in matching materials we have had
one objection to scheme and it's from
the tenants of the house living the
adjoining house to the left of it and
yet in relation to that property it's
compliant with SPD for and on that basis
it's recommended for approval
I'll take those drawings down now but I
can bring them back up if you wish nice
sermon Thank You mr. Pierson that would
anybody like to speak to this item
yeah yessiree yeah I have a double used
to visit I think we're officers report
is absolutely correct
I can't see any reason whatsoever to
object and would propose that we the
reporters accepted Thank You counselor
Rigby and anybody looking to second that
beats a second that I appreciate their
husband the one representation objecting
to the application but I think on
balance I agree with what was said by
mr. Pierson that it is only a mother
modest amendment so I'm happy to second
the application you counselor William
Duncan I think it is a modest extension
it's a change for the people at 132 what
they used to but I don't think it's so
substantial that we have any grounds to
refuse it it was within our time so I'll
be supporting the application and if
there's no other speakers it's been
moved and seconded that we grant me
supplication and I'll go to the voles
and just bear with me everybody and
councillor dr. Barkley are you for or
against the application thank you I
suppose recommendation to approve
comfortably carry I support draft his
recommendation Thank You council
accordingly
support the officers recommendation jyu
councillor Hartley thank you a greedy
officers recommendation to approve the
application thank you comes with your
own to approve morgan sport officers
recommendation to please
Thank You councillor Proctor ought
officers recommendation to approve Thank
You councillor Rigby support the
officers recommendation to approve and
Keith councilman Williams that's the
fourth officer recommendations okay 19q
councillor winds family to approve Thank
You councillor Thomas
support the officers recommendation to
approve you and I'll be supporting the
officers recommendation to approve so
that's unanimous decision that
application has been granted thank you
everybody
the next item is 33 instant wave that's
on page 62 of your paper agenda and we
have an introduction from miss Millman
mr. Millman are you there I am thank you
care oh my
all right
relates to 33 and stern Lane in a
terrace property house back the
application proposes a three meter
install bifold windows on the rear
elevation council employee and I
apologize in your report applicant but
it's the agent and we have achieved one
objection that was detailed within your
main committee report however in the
additional information report your
notation has now been withdrawn and that
was three meetings compliant with a cd4
it is proportionate scale the property
and do the by sold windows in the rear
elevation there thank you thank you mr.
Millman to speak to this well I'll speak
to it they're napping is quite a modest
application and obviously that our
concerns is that when an application and
obsess the neighbors and and and and
they don't like it but they had an
objection previously owned it and they
withdrew it and so they're quite
comfortable with it and certainly it
falls within our guidelines so when I
have no hesitation in proposing that we
grant this and counsel Morgan you'd like
to come in
yeah thanks chair and III I see no
reason to oppose this and I was just
really to make point I I until his
mother had said that the neighborhood
withdrawn their objection I did
understand the objection I did
understand their view it just fill in
some of the gaps but there's no reason
to object on this so I'm happy to
seconds approving this Thank You
councillor Morgan and if nobody asks
which is to speak how he's gonna move in
secondly that we grant me supplication
I'll go through everybody and quite the
votes
so counselor dr. Barkley Thank You
chairman I support the recommendation to
approve Thank You councillor Carrie
Thank You chairman I also support the
recommendation to approve Thank You
council accordingly support the
recommendation to council honestly Thank
You chair I support the recommendation
to approve thank you they comes with
your own ocean sports and thanks Jen you
councillor Proctor or the recommendation
to approve thanks to you councillor
Rigby Thank You councillor Williams as
Support Officer recommendation to
approve Minister Thank You Stanley
Thank You councillor Thomas support the
opposite of the officers recommendation
thank you
and I'll be supporting your choice
recommendation so again that is
unanimous and applications been approved
thank you everybody
46
oh well rolling sale and that's 140 to
do painting for two of you old paper
agenda and we have an introduction from
mr. Coley Coley Thank You chairman are
you able to say that the information on
the screen I am yes very good this
application is also being reported
the application properties of semi
detached dwelling on the north side of
Belleville Road which is within sale you
can see it there and the application
proposes to erect a single-story side
and rear extension which is part of the
building here and there are the external
alterations including the windows the
single-story side extension will project
from the side animation by 1.7 meters it
will retain a gap with nine three meters
to the shared boundary it's a number
forty-four fell wall Road which is on
this this side the extension would have
a depth of book four point seven meters
it would project by four point four
meters from the front a common boundary
with number 48 which is on this side so
that's a longer projection that wall as
you can see comes slightly forward so it
so it's a deeper extension here by the
width of the wall and the width of the
extension would be 7.5 meters the P
considerations in this application of
design appearance in residential
immunity and no objections have been
received the developments compliant with
SPD for and considered to be of
appropriate scale and design they were
being keeping with the street scene a
thermal Road therefore recommended for
approval their elevation see there and
some photographs so it will be going in
that this part of the property here
Thank You chairman thank you mr. Kohli
I'll speak on this reasonable palms
modest again there's no impact on
amenity there's been no representations
always a good sign so I'd be happy to
approve this Thank You chair thank you
John I'll take it that you happy to move
the application project yeah happy - yes
and counselling Stanley like to speak to
it yeah happy
second the approval it's now a guideline
just thinking about the neighborhoods
that's down so we have second approval
in Lyon Oscar recommendation Thank You
councilman Stanley anybody else wish to
comment and just can I just say that the
only concern possibly anybody might have
had is an effect on the street scene but
I don't see that happen in any way shape
or form so it is a modest application
you will be able to see it perhaps from
the front but it's certainly one cause a
terrace in effect and and it's a very
welcomed application so it's been moved
and seconded that we grant this and I'll
go to a vote
counselor dr. bad boy I support the
officers recommendation to approve Thank
You chairman I vote to grant you council
accordingly support officers
recommendation to you comfortable
hopefully thank you Support Officer
recommendation to it pretty councillor
Jerome Thank You councillor Morgan spot
us the recommendations to approve what
officer recommendation to approve
councillor Rigby Counsell Williams
Support Officer recommendation to
approve Thank You councillor wings
family to improve thank you
comes with Thomas support the opposition
to approve thank you to improve so again
that is unanimous that application has
been granted thank you everybody
and the last item agenda tonight is the
11 Grange Road in sale and ash no mercy
and that's on page 115 of your paper
agenda and we have an introduction from
slows slows thank you I will end this
application linked to an 11 Grange Road
and its before members this evening as
the agent is employee of the council is
a two-story house and it features a part
single pot two-story rear outrigger and
number 9 Grange Road features IMAX our
outrigger with a slightly and single
story the proposal is for the existing
be demolished and the erection of a
single-story rear extension wrapping
around the outrigger width of 5 meters
and adapts for four point eight meters
and features a flat roof and with a
maximum height of three point two five
metres all materials are proposed to
match and the development notable harm
to the design and parents of the area
all residential amenity appropriate
height fail in design which would be in
keeping with the surrounding area and
the host dwelling officers are therefore
recommending approval of the application
Thank You mr. Lowe's thank you and
anybody wishing to speak to this yes
Lawrence councillor rebate thank
officers for the report
straightforward reports I can't see any
reason whatsoever to refuse on planning
ground and I'll just simply propose
grant nice application Thank You comes
the rig becomes a half way Thank You Jer
I'm happy to second counselor would be
sir motioned a tweet that we that we
approve nope no concerns
I know there are they recommend
distances to the houses at the rear are
are less than the recommended distance
is in SPD for but you know the housing
around that area is
is compact it's quite dense and I think
we can see from the plans the hair is to
the rear on some Mary's Road are offset
slightly a bit of an angle so agree with
the officers report that there's there's
no concerns there on on residential
meaning say so happy to second counselor
with this motion thank you thank you
thank you canceling out for your
comments and okay the movement seconded
that we grab this and don't think any of
the members wish to speak so we'll go to
a vote and councillor dr. Barkley
I support the officers recommendation to
grant Thank You councillor Carey Thank
You chairman I support as the Grunk
recommendation council accordingly
support the officers recommendations a
grant
thank you comes behalf Lee support the
officer recommendation to grant thank
you
Thank You councilman Jerome ocean to
grant Thank You councillor Morgan sport
officer recommendation to grant a
recommendation to count you can sleeping
yes support the officers recommendation
to grant um Thank You councillor Ian and
Support Officer recommendations but
thank you Thank You councillor Gittings
family yes recommendations Brennan thank
you comes with summer support the
recommendation to drum you I'll be
supporting the officers recommendation
to so again that is unanimous that the
case is being granted and there's no
other items on the agenda so that
concludes the meeting and thank you with
my other a two minute discussion if
there